I think Kelly and I just agree to
disagree you know how I feel ladies we
are too special to be arguing over a guy
all you women watch that yes Kelly Ripa
came for bachelor nation this week
slamming the franchise for pitting women
against each other I don't think anybody
can really get it until you're there on
Thursday et sat down with the current
Bachelorette Hannah brown just moments
after she came face-to-face with Kelly
on live TV
I am very against women fighting over it
I don't believe in it it's not women
fighting against each other ultimately
it was one of the most empowering things
I ever have done because I had to push
myself and grow as an individual and I
did I also at first was very skeptical
of the show but I'm here now and I
wouldn't be the Bachelorette if I didn't
believe in the process and how it's made
me so empowered to be myself I think I
struggled everybody saw me struggle and
wanting to be a certain way that I that
I'm just not and I think it this whole
show empowered me to be Who I am and be
and a strong empowered woman along the
way and instead of fighting I made
friends and I hope she picked up on that
we're all not fight angry or really
encouraging each other we're gonna
hopefully be here yeah and I don't like
to think you're a purple person whatever
has been said and taken differently than
it was supposed to I'm sorry for that no
I apologize too
so Hannah left the bachelor with
girlfriends but will she walk away with
a fiance on the Bachelorette my heart
right now is like just filled with
happiness I'm excited for everyone to be
a part of my experience in the journey
that I had I will tell you that I'm
happy and ultimately this season and how
it all turned out is not how I thought
it would be it just wasn't doesn't mean
that it's not good I think it happened
the exact way that it was supposed to
and I feel really excited and blessed to
had the opportunity
I've had and feel really good and once
y'all oughta see what that is
[Music]